dans les administrations de la ville le
créole est une langue officielle et ce
n'est certainement pas par hasard
avec près de 500 mille haïtiens new york
est la deuxième capitale d'haïti
l'homme le plus en vue de la communauté
c'est lui le docteur mathieu eugène le
premier élu haïtien a siégé au conseil
municipal de new york
maintenant on va dès la session du but
nous allons voter nous allons prendre
des décisions et à wayaux pour en
arriver là mathieu gênes a dû serrer
quelques pinces la politique à
l'américaine se fait dans la rue
il ne faut oublier personne et encore
moins les compatriotes quand les temps
sont durs
haïti est dans une situation critique
maintenant dans une situation est
pénible surtout après ça a été mal avant
mais ça devient pire surtout après le
tremblement de terre du 12 janvier 2010
un tremblement de terre de magnitude 7,7
sur l'échelle de richter dévasté haïti
et eu deux cent cinquante mille
personnes
dix mois plus tard un million et demi
d'haïtiens s'entassent encore dans des
camps de fortune
la situation sanitaire désastreuse une
épidémie de choléra a déjà fait
plusieurs centaines de morts
le palais présidentiel est en ruines et
dans trois semaines des haïtiens devront
élire un nouveau président le pays le
plus pauvre du continent américain est
complètement exsangue retour à new york
au conseil municipal nous retrouvons le
docteur eugène il tente encore et
toujours de lever des fonds our latino
des spas des fautes battue à peine deux
ans depuis perth aux frais des estivants
chaque vendredi dans la mairie du
district de mathieu eugène il y a fool
ici les haïtiens arrivés sur le sol
américain avant la catastrophe viennent
chercher un précieux sésame
le tpf ses trois filles protection stats
cela veut dire une protection temporaire
disons pour les a et c qui vivait aux
états unis sans être le tps une mesure
d'exception un droit d'asile temporaires
dont mathieu eugène fut le promoteur
objectif régulariser tous les haïtiens
sans papiers résidant aux états unis
avant le séisme le tremblement de terre
vraiment nous a donné l'opportunité bien
dégueu l'appliquer c'est de travailler
les trouver
lire ici on se relaie pour les prix avec
la famille là bas j'ai joué le moins à
la voie moi on voit mois la faim la
maladie et tout mais pour les haïtiens
arrivés après la catastrophe aucun
espoir d'obtenir des papiers
cette jeune femme elle est arrivée à
paris le 12 janvier elle est venue ici
pour voir comment on peut l'aider à
travailler en a l'habitude de travail on
a fait pas mal travaillé on n'est pas
libre et puis j'aimerais continuer aussi
continuer à aller à l'école c'est bien
qu marie-edith aura bien du mal à
reprendre ses études sans papiers elle
cherchera des petits boulots non
déclarés lorsqu'un haïtien débarque à
new york
il se dirige à brooklyn ici vit
l'essentiel de la diaspora haïtienne
c'est donc d'ici que s'élève la voix la
plus écoutée de la communauté rico
dupuis et le directeur de radio soleil
d'haïti
madame monsieur bonsoir et bienvenue
dans cette émission voisin vérité son
antenne diffuse en anglais créole et
français une tribune d'envergure pour
tous les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle du 28 novembre
après deux mandats l'actuel président
préval doit passer la main
oui si vous voulez ouargla après trois
heures le rdnp c'est l'un des principaux
partis politiques candidats à la
présidence d'haïti nous appellent
souvent du parti politique ah ben je
suis drôle c il appelle les sept jours
s'ils vont appeler beaucoup plus grave
et de moi parce que c'est la période du
temps ils savent qu'ils font passer par
new york pour se faire hier mais c'est
tellement important
d'abord pour se financer ils viennent
tous organisé des collectes de fonds des
levées de fonds ici à new york et donc
il faut faire la promotion de cela et
même et c'est pas seulement pour les
levées de fonds il y a également la
légitimité cognac donne la légitimité de
new york
mesurons là ce soir dans le centre de
manhattan au new york metropolitan
college rico participent à la conférence
d'une association d'expatriés le thème
le poids de la diaspora dans la
reconstruction du pays
à l'aube de l'élection présidentielle il
va dire pour haïtienne emploie plus de 1
milliard de dollars environ un milliard
de dollars à haïti sont là des recours à
ces s'est fait chier c'est vraiment
grave dans le pays car les milliards de
la diaspora ont une limite
la constitution haïtienne qui ne
reconnaît pas la double nationalité
interdit le droit de vote aux expatriés
mon sens fils du pays
nous avons les mêmes droits que étant
ici aux etats-unis haïtien nous avons
beaucoup non seulement le temps
d'informer mais nous leur donnons à
manger ici le nerf de la guerre c'est
l'argent et leur souhait le plus cher
fair de new york l'épicentre de la
reconstruction politique du pays
[Musique]
et
pour trouver le conseiller municipal
mathieu eugène un dimanche matin à
brooklyn
il suffit de se rendre à l'église c'est
ici que se trouve ses électeurs vous
savez c'est un moment très triste et
tragique dans l'histoire du peuple
haïtien mais à cause de leur foi en dieu
ils ont pu surmonter ce moment difficile
[Musique]
et
la famille et le pays sur dans tous les
champs toutes les prières ici pour les
paroissiens la solidarité n'est pas une
question de milliards mais de ce soir on
avait toujours été sur le dos mais
encore plus affecté après le séisme on
est obligé de faire de travail de
travail et de jo pour pouvoir subvenir
aux besoins et de la famille s'en
nourrit ce n'est pas le gym a été ça
c'est très cher en ce mois de l'élection
présidentielle la foi n'est pas seule
porteuse d'espoirs sur les ruines de la
catastrophe tous les haïtiens espère
voir pousser une démocratie
[Musique]